tax the people who are making billions  of dollars some of it perhaps  legitimately look they may have come up  with a great idea they see the digital  revolution  they understand it's transforming an  industry they're at the forefront of  leading that  great celebrate it but then they have to  pay a tax  so that society can transition but  that's where the real tax is don't go  after the person  who's making a few hundred thousand uh  it already  uh has a couple kids in college in the  suburbs i mean look make sure it goes up  to 39  but that's not you don't want to stop  the the middle class or even the upper  middle class  you want to do is say we've got we're  going to prioritize the working class  we're going to look out for the middle  class and upper middle class but we're  really going to get the revenue  from the big corporations and the ultra  rich